لذا، فلنتحدث بن فقط عن حقيقة
أن لديك أه الكثير من الدبلوماسيين العرب
أه الكثير من القادة في العالم العربي
يجتمعون يحاولون الدعوة إلى وقف إطلاق النار
فيما يتعلق بما يحدث في الحرب
في غزة سواء الولايات المتحدة أو إسرائيل الآن
القول بأن وقف إطلاق النار ببساطة غير
ممكن لأنه بالطبع سيعطي
حماس اليد العليا، فقط قم بتوجيهنا
عبر ذلك نعم، من
الواضح أن هناك
تناقضًا واضحًا للغاية بين
موقف الولايات المتحدة الرافض
لوقف إطلاق النار وما نسمعه
تقريبًا  مجمل
القيادة العربية التي ستجتمع في
قمة طارئة في العاصمة السعودية
الرياض المتحدث باسم الجامعة العربية
أه قائلا الجامعة العربية تطالب
بضبط فوري للنار وأكد أنهم
غير معنيين بهذه
الوقفات الإنسانية التي  لقد شبه الكثيرون في
العالم العربي أه مجرد
تقديم الطعام لشخص ما أثناء
تعرضه للضرب حتى الموت أه لذلك من
الصعب أن نقول ما الذي سيتمكن هؤلاء القادة العرب من
فعله أه نظرًا لأنهم
لم يستخدموا أي نوع من
غير  -الأسلحة العسكرية الموجودة تحت تصرفهم
على سبيل المثال الحظر النفطي العربي كما
حدث في عام
1973 تحت قيادة الملك السعودي آنذاك
أه فيصل الآن يحدث أيضًا في الرياض
ستكون قمة
منظمة المؤتمر الإسلامي
واحدة أخرى من هذه الشرق الأوسط
المتاجر الناطقة التي لا تحقق
الكثير حقًا، الأمر المثير للاهتمام هو أن إبراهيم
ري، رئيس إيران، سيكون
هناك، وهذه هي المرة الأولى التي
يزور فيها رئيس إيراني المملكة العربية السعودية منذ
وقت طويل جدًا، ووفقًا
لمتحدث باسم ra if the  منظمة
المؤتمر الإسلامي أه القمة
لا تسفر عن تخفيف
العنف في غزة يقول ربما
يتسع الصراع الآن ذكرتم
سابقا زيارة الأمير القطري إلى
أه القاهرة أمس أيضا أه رئيس
المكتب السياسي لحركة حماس  هانية ورئيس
الجهاد الإسلامي ذهبا للقاء
عباس الجمل رئيس
المخابرات المصرية مما يشير بالتأكيد إلى أن
المصريين أه يحاولون دفع
الوضع إلى الأمام ربما يحاولون
إقناع حماس والجهاد الإسلامي اللذين
يحتجزان أيضًا
بعض هؤلاء الأسرى في غزة
البدء بطريقة ما في إطلاق سراح بعضهم
ربما للسماح بوقف
إطلاق النار إن لم يكن دائمًا، على الأقل مؤقتًا.
زين صحيح، بن ويدمان يعيش لنا هناك،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك